foreign
Tracy is with us in Fort Myers Florida
hi Tracy how are you
you too how can we help
so yesterday I was laid off
uh well you know sounds like it was
unexpected
it was however I'm in a rare situation
from I think a lot of a lot on that I
recently came into some inheritance a
decent chunk I am completely debt free
including the house
um so and it's within like my mom died
on Christmas Day and I it's it's all
this has been a heck of a year anyway
um thank you and so I my job I'm in HR I
had sleep privileges where I worked and
so the irony is I sold my personal car
that I hadn't driven in a year last week
and now I have 13 days to get a car so
no notice at all on this layoff that's
just weird no yeah I mean it's it is
what it is I'm just trying to roll with
the punches and I think the the scariest
part for me is I now have more money
than I've ever had and I still and you
know you're not supposed to make big
major decisions with grief being so
recent I what was the car that you sold
last week what was it
it was a 2012 Hyundai Elantra and what
did you sell it for
four thousand and they put it online for
8 900. whoa they turn around re-flipped
it on you huh oh yeah I mean the
pictures while I was waiting for them to
come back with how much they were going
to give me they the the pictures that I
had to place and everything on it that
um they end up bringing back to me so it
was crazy but
um How much money how much money do you
have in cash
oh I have over 500 000. okay so go buy a
car what's the problem well because I am
not used to having this kind of money in
my mindset
should go get a cheap car a hoopty but I
know after working in the realm that
I've worked in where I could drive a
different car all the time I know what I
want I'm just afraid to spend that kind
of money because I've never had that
choice before so I just feel like I need
permission from you to say yeah go out
and spend 40 000 on you I really want a
Jeep Grand Cherokee okay but they're
expensive
okay and you're buying a one-year-old
one or something
a couple years yeah I don't know that
I'd want to go more than two or three
okay what did you make at your job that
you got lost
75 and what are you going to make at the
next job 85
I hope so and honestly I'm kind of I'm
not I don't know that I need to look
right now with the holidays and I need
to it's going to be crazy with the first
year without my mom she died on
Christmas day so I think this is a sign
that I should just kind of not rush into
anything until maybe after the first of
the year you guys tell me but that's
kind of where I'm thinking right now
okay there's two separate questions on
the table number one let's deal with the
easy one go buy a car and yes you can
afford it you can afford a forty
thousand dollar car you have a half
million dollars cash in the bank you
make it you make eighty thousand dollars
a year you do not want to buy a seventy
thousand dollar car
no I would never do not need to buy it
well you might I mean I'm just making
sure okay okay and uh but I mean if I
wouldn't spend more than half of what
you think you're going to be making
okay so 40 with you making 80 is okay
60 with you making 80s not okay right
just because you got the money okay so
that that would be my guideline and so
that gives you permission to do a lot
and just take and take your time on that
go rent your car for a week so you're
not in a hurry and get and pay too much
for a car and that's what I was afraid
of yeah just slow down go just go down
the rental car place and rent a car for
a week okay and just rent what you think
you want to drive by the way go ahead
and rent you a Jeep Cherokee well the
irony is that I just got laid off from a
rental car company so that's why I know
what I want to drive
two years I've been almost two years of
driving pretty much whatever I like
on to the next question and I want my
career expert next to me to step in but
I'm gonna before he does I'm just gonna
be Papa Dave okay okay you lost your mom
and then you surprise got kicked in the
teeth
and you walked in and got devalued
instantaneously last week
mm-hmm
so you're confident your confidence is a
little bit shaken
and um I would prefer you get back on
the horse quicker than the first of the
year for that reason because I want you
to get back on the horse because I want
you to regain some of your some of your
Swagger
yeah
and just The Grieving of your mom which
is fine and normal and you should but
also in the middle of that you had
somebody walk in and say you don't have
any value hit the street and I I want to
tell you you got a lot of value
thank you and when you land that new job
that's them telling you you've got a lot
of value and I don't want you to wait
till the first of the year to hear that
message again
that's just Papa Dave talking but Ken no
I appreciate it no I I agree with that
um because you're really a victim of a
lot of fear out there around recession
and things like this and a lot of
companies they staff up and then they
staff down and this really wasn't
personal at all that's why you really
didn't even see it coming we hear about
this every day my question is do you
have a severance at all
uh yeah just two weeks because I've not
been there quite two years yeah well I I
think I would Echo Dave and what I want
you to do though is I like the idea of
reflection and you've got you've got at
least a month uh you know you know of
just kind of going where do I want to go
and looking into all of the
possibilities but you know one of the
the big hiring times for a lot of
companies is it in November and so I I
would actually take advantage of of
getting back on the horse pre-holiday we
still have a very hot job economy so I
want you thinking now because you've got
Financial Freedom what is it that you
really want to do and why do you want to
do it and I'm just curious you got
something in the top of your mind
without trying to make it sound pretty
but it's something that you would do
what is it tell me
I've always want to be in real estate
but I'm afraid because the market is so
saturated with Realtors
Market slowed down that calls them out
pretty quick yeah I mean I've thought
about this for 10 years and I've just
never done it because because the people
who are in it that I've that I've asked
the questions I mean they're real you're
going to pay a lot of things out of your
own pocket you might not make money the
first year you know it's that's scary
now I have that freedom I know I could
but I'm still it's still hot it's hard
for me to wrap my head around the amount
of money that I have and so in my mind I
keep trying to forget about it so that I
don't go crazy well okay so I want Dave
to comment on the real estate the guy's
been in real estate a long time and he
knows but I just want to tell you
something that now is the time for you
to do this you've been thinking about
this for 10 years you didn't ask for
permission for me on this issue I'm
going to give you permission without you
asking you need to get qualified now now
is the time for you to get studied up
and and I want you to find some
different real estate people who have a
much different Outlook you've been
hanging around some people who are
giving you the negatives I don't need to
know the context of those conversations
but the fact is you can win and you can
win big even in this real estate economy
if you are committed to do it committed
to get good at it committed to work with
a a broker who's going to Mentor you and
guide you and invest in you you can do
this yeah and you need to do it starting
next week go ahead and get your license
signed up for to take your test and jump
in and find a broker and and get all
your groundwork and everything and done
this fall to where January 1 you hit the
ground running wide open
cooking with gash in January one yeah
yeah in a new chair in in a used Jeep
Cherokee
and listen if you make zero money for
six months and it starts to scare you go
get a job
okay after January okay right but uh but
yeah but I think you you take the time
align yourself with a great broker get
the groundwork because it's going to
take a little while to study for sit for
take the test get the results back get
signed up the board of realtors all the
stuff you do you gotta you know it takes
a hot minute to get to get set up you
don't just walk in and in a week you're
selling real estate in most cases anyway
and so um yeah that's exactly what I do
I would start I'll just go ahead it's
time burn the ships you know it's an old
phrase that you do just just you
approach the island you burn the ship
I'm all in I'm not going to no way home
no way out of this deal you know Dave
that is true about real estate or any
sales job that's that straight
commission you at some point you got to
commit to go I'm not going to quit
I'm going to do whatever it takes and
and you know in Fort Myers Florida
you're gonna be just fine yeah you're
gonna be just fine that's correct it's
not exactly a slow Market
yeah and it's not like you have to wait
till Winter's over you're in Fort
freaking Myers I mean come on